E
UL
MY KELL URT I IS T CRITIC OF PU
S IN PRISON IND S LE
HE TOLD CNT  LIKELY T
>> CLEAR
BUT HEKILL VY MA PEOPLIF THE   I
ST
BEFORE, BUT AT THEBSIN O
POPULATION. LOOKI LA
LOSE THEN A  IS POSSIBLE
CHIEF SECURITY A FORME
.REAT TO
YOTU PIECE WASHI
DOES FEAR A , BUT NOT BY HISOLI.
IS TA LIVE BY THE
KGB, DIETHKG OF
SCENARIO?I THINIT-  SYSTE RUNDER
BRANCH
GOHE UNITED
STAT, AND IN RUSSI'SU'VE PUTTHE
ESNT MEYYPIGARCHS WHO E
THE D TO
HE WAS TURNED INJAIL, DO
HAVE SE CONTROL.
THEY'VE GOT PI
THEY EXERT A  OF CONTROL, BUT E
HAVE THEHEWIRITY OFFICIALS
THE ARMEFOE TH'V
INTELLIGENCEHEVE
Y TO OPERA ELY.
I THINK THAT FIO
N T ITIS
REMINISCENT, OF COURSE,  WHAT
19HEAS A COUP
AGAINST
SO TT' OF, I THINKTHE
DS MSEL WE'RE ALL SEEING THESE
S OF PUTINE
HUG  FROM
INS IT
SETY P L OF STRA  , PEOPLE IN OL
ABOUT IT.
THN NDEAE OF TS  OF
BEFORE, ORLLY
I MEAN, ITPEAR THAT OF THINGS.
SENEERED, THE SPUTNIK SHOTVACCI
DIDN'T HAVA LOT OF FTH.LLY IS I
LEE THERE'S
T T OFPLWHO
HAVEIRT ACCESS TO HI
ENO,T
KEKNOW, IT NA TYPICASI
D OPENVIEWS.THUT, ERHE. VEME
FUN THF ION AS WELL.
N' TNK
YOU KNOW, MEBODY'S GOING TO UN
HIM, YOU KNOW, WITH THE TIMBREL
HAPPENGAINST HIMW BADLIT NOTT IN
UKRAINE BUT ALSO, I DON'TH ONCT,
OING TO NLY GOIN UNFOLMO
>> YOUEEN A TALK, STEVEN, IN TT
BOGUR THE
CHEMICAL, ACCUSI
UK KNOW,
PLOTTINGN THRE HAVING,YOU KNOW,V
WEAP TRT OF OUDEE,AT THACO USE
PRETPUTIN, FRUIAE
WEAPONS.
SOTO ARE YOUTHOUGHTS ON HOW DO
-- THAL  DOES YOU DON'T HAVEO
U CAN GO BACK TO THE SYRIAN
WA'S -- T OF THOSE
THAT WERE  RECALE DEHAT N HAD W
BA THERE.
OF COURSE THEY WER
WOULD  NEE THSERIOUS.ANNIHILATE
CITY IN  CASE.
NTEXPLOTHER, YOUNO
ORICAL EXAMPLE
SORT OOVOCATIONAPROPAGANDACALE R
ATTEMPTED ACTION.MEMBER
'80s IT WAS TH
PENTAGON THOUGHT UP AN
ABOUT THAT
SO THIS IS -THIANS HAVE
NG THIDECADES.
THEY'RE RY GOOD AT IT, AND
WHEN YOU A